hi hi hi welcome to the monitor as
always I don't know why I say that every
week but as always I am Peter Reuben
senior editor at Wired bringing you the
best in pop culture this week we have a
comic book written by a kid we have a
documentary from a man who's really old
enough to know better but first we have
the single of the week not doing an
album this week we're doing a single why
are we doing a single because hallowed
entertainment television network adult
swim for the third year in a row is
doing their singles program which is
every week during the summer they put
out a totally exclusive download by a
different group this year they've got
the hives they've got waves but this
weeks and the one that I am explicitly
talking about is flying lotus featuring
Earl Sweatshirt and captain Murphy and
the track is called between friends now
what's interesting about this is not
necessarily that we have Earl Sweatshirt
making a rare appearance outside The Odd
Future crew but who is captain Murphy
he's rapping but no knows who captain
Murphy is of course captain Murphy is
one of the characters from classic adult
swim show Sealab but we don't know who
he is as an MC so people are saying
maybe it's Tyler the Creator I've seen a
couple people online saying it sounds
like a sub rock to them I say nay I say
judging from the guys flow judging from
a little bit of the subject matter he
talks about I think it's just Flying
Lotus with a slowed-down voice this is a
time-honored tradition of rappers
changing their voices and appearing
incognito Delahunt funky homosapien did
it of course but I'm getting off track
the point is that the song is great
great flying load of production really
nice uncharacteristically mellow rapping
versus by Earl but it still sounds great
and it's free so download it though it
in your playlist between friends okay
next up we have a ridiculous documentary
but fun nonetheless so let's go to a man
on the scene
thank you okay so you know those
priceline commercials and there's this
actor on him talks kind of funny name is
William Shatner now before the price on
commercials William Shatner really made
his name doing the show called Boston
Legal duh right well before Boston Legal
William Shatner was on the show called
Star Trek Star Trek was on in the 40s or
something anyway was kind of a big deal
and he thought it was a big enough deal
to actually make a documentary about
Trekkies it's called William Shatner's
get a life and it premieres this Friday
on Epix what is epics I am glad I asked
epics is a cable network / subscription
video streaming service you may have it
on your cable plan you may need to
subscribe to it through xbox or Roku or
or whatever your living room box is
however let's get back to William
Shatner's get a life when Shatner says
I've been to all these cons over my
career and Star Trek has has followed me
throughout my career however I don't
really know anything about it so he
takes his camera crew and he hits the
cons and he talks to cast mates from his
original iteration of Star Trek he talks
to cast members from subsequent Star
Trek shows and of course he talks to the
fans and they're perfectly replica
Starfleet uniforms it's a lot of fun and
because it is kind of the avatar of Star
Trek himself the fans are geeked
everyone's geek if you get epics
definitely check it out William
Shatner's get a life okay thank you for
that now now comic book of the week
there has been for a few years now a
webcomic called axe cop and it is
written by well he's eight years old now
he started when he was five or six a kid
named Malachai Nicolle and it's drawn by
his older brother Ethan who is a comic
illustrator so of course it has all the
necessary professional sheen of a great
comic but dark horse as now is now
bringing out the first print exclusive
version of axe cop it is called axe cop
president of the world and it's just
it's it's so entertaining it has all
those things that you remember from
trying to write stories and write and
draw comics when you were eight it has
hilariously named villains it has
beasley over-the-top action and just
concepts and axe cop himself is it
seriously maybe one of the best comic
heroes in in recent memory it's like if
if magnum p.i and Chuck Norris and the
the guy from Simon and Simon the one
with the mustache if they all got
together and and somehow maids we really
love and they had a baby who then grew
up in the future to be even more badass
that would be axe cop got the aviator
shades he's got the ridiculous
ridiculous brush mustache and he's got
an axe but pick it up this week it is it
is just endless endless fun and I cannot
recommend it highly enough but that is
it for this week on the monitor we will
be back next week but until then email
us at the monitor at wired.com I need
both my fingers so you can see exactly
what I'm pointing at let us know what
we've missed let us know we should be
covering let us know how you feel about
us and until then inspirational
catchphrase here
you